I remember a week or so ago you talked about entitlement, I heard that and so I don't want this to be taken the wrong way, but I had a bad couple of weeks and then I had a good day yesterday and then late at night I developed a urinary tract infection just like out of nowhere, so I went to the rife machine and I ran it twice in a row.
And it seemed like it relieved a little bit of pain, but then I slept through the night and then I ran it again in the morning and I started just getting like really horrible pain so that I finally had to go to the doctor and do the antibiotics and I just kind of feel like, you know, when will the rife machine ever work for me? I don't, you know, I know it can't work all the time but how about some times?
Like am I not using it right or what is going wrong?
So I think that's a valid question, so you have to take it in a perspective. It's, it did the rife work to knock out your bacterial infection? No, it didn't.
You used the bacterial program or what did you use?
It's called the UTI program, so if you're using the rife remember it to tool, so it's frequency specific. So the UTI infection is a bacterial program.
And so, but it's set on certain bacteria because you just can't put all the bacterial programs in in a short, I think it's an hour program or something, isn't it?
Yeah.
So always look at other programs. So let's say I run the UTI program a couple of times and boy, this isn't really helping.
You should switch to go to a bacterial program, go to a strep program, go to a staff program, do a viral come to the viral come flex program, switch programs because it's frequencies. That's number one.
Number two is hitting a bacteria with its own frequencies. If it's a very viral bacteria where it be it's currently in a state of very rapid replication, it might not be enough to knock it out. That's where you have to use other tools.
So that's where I don't think it was unwise. If you at all to go and get a antibiotic and I don't think that you should think that you something wasn't working that you had to use a bigger bullet on that to that situation.
So I would continue even getting the antibiotic, I would continue to run the bacterial and the UTI and the viral programs of it because it will do nothing but help help knock it down. It's just like, it's just like, OK, well, somebody took Euroco, which is something we as a supplement, we usually give for people with UTIs.
And Sally took Euroco for her UTI and knocked it down and I took it. It didn't work. Oh my gosh, how come this doesn't work? Well, it didn't work for you because yours was a little bit different. It was in a rapid replication. You got to use a different tool.
So just go to a different tool like you did. That was good idea. Maybe it's time to get an antibiotic.
I've heard the same stories of I went got an antibiotic for my UTI and it didn't work. What should I do? Well, doesn't need antibiotics are bad for UTIs. It just didn't work for yours that time.
It yours is a different strain that needs something else. So let's try a donation. Let's try some Euroco. Let's try a type viral. So you just got to try different tools.
Do you have a suggestion for a preventive consists of something that I kind of have a history of and with being on chemo. I'm at higher risk of infections and stuff.
So with UTIs, I think some of the things that you need to consider is the reason why do women get UTIs and men don't seem to get UTIs. I think there's a reason.
The reason is that women have a uterus and your uterus sits in front of a bladder and as we are going to just mute everybody again.
So as we as we age our uterus can tip at our bladder tips with it. So then you're in control and not get fully drained when we go to your aid.
So some of the hints that I tell people that I'm really pro to UTIs. I have a history of UTIs. Well, is it, it's not really, oh, we need to use, you know, just use stronger medication all the time or oh, you need to use the right for all the time. You have to go back and ask that one little three word question, three letter question, why am I getting UTIs all the time.
And many times it's because my bladder's tipped.
So our bladder typically tips forward and that's what causes the pool either that in like an interior little cup of the bladder. So we have to tip the bladder back.
So it's really impossible for me to explain that without showing that to you or having a practitioner that's near you that knows how to tip the bladder and tip the uterus because they both go together that can really help with that.
But it's not just with with with our older there's younger women that anatomically have a tipped bladder part. There's a lot of reasons to it many times when you know, ladies are athletic.
That tend to get very tight and the bladder of the uterus just tips forward. So those are just other reasons why a person's probe to
bladder infections. And I think you need to address those things as well because it's just not, it's not, it's not a normal thing for a person to say, well, I've just probed to bladder infections and I get a lot of bladder infections. There's a reason why.
So many times it's structural things. Other structural things are you go to a chiropractor. Is there a neurological impeachment on the nerve that's affecting the bladder that could be a cause to it.
Another chemical cause of constant bladder infections can be due to food sensitivities.
So most of our patients are on more restricted diet. So that's not quite an issue. But gluten sensitivity and dairy sensitivity are common with recurrent bladder infections too.